SHE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE.
HACKERS ARE TRYING TO USE THEIR
SKILLS TO REACH THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE.
>> YOU SHOULD SEE ALL THESE
PEOPLE REFUGEES FROM UKRAINE,
PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND ME.
A HACKERS FIGHTING AGAINST
RUSSIA'S INFORMATION WAR.
A WE KNEW THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
ALL AROUND THE WORLD WHO WOULD
LIKE TO DO SOMETHING, BUT
STOPPED BY A GUN.
>> THIS MAN PART OF THE QUAD
ONLINE ACTIVISTS IN POLAND WHO
BUILT A TOOL TO LET ANYONE SEND
TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAILS TO
GIVE
THEM MORE ABOUT THE WAR TO GET
AROUND VLADIMIR PUTIN'S IRON
CURTAIN.
RUSSIA RECENTLY CUT OFF ACCESS
TO FACEBOOK AND TWITTER.
>> THERE IS A NEW GROUP THAT
CAME OUT WITH A WEBSITE TO
ALLOW
YOU TO TEXT RUSSIAN CELL
PHONES.
>> SO HOW MANY TEXT MESSAGES DO
YOU THINK YOU HAVE SENT TO
RUSSIANS OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS?
>> THREE, FOUR, FIVE, SIX,
THUNDERSHOWERS.
I CAN'T COUNT.
IT KEEPS GOING.
>> A TRUCK SALESMAN HAS
MESSAGED
RUSSIANS AND MOST DON'T GET HIM
A RESPONSES AND OTHERS SAY GO
AWAY, BUT OTHERS ENGAGE.
>> I HAD A GENTLEMAN EARLY ON
THAT REACHED OUT TO ME AND SENT
A PICTURE OF WHERE HE IS
WORKING
AND I SENT HIM HOW WE LIKE TO
TRAX SO I SENT HIM PICTURES OF
MY TRAXES AND HE SENT ME
PICTURES OF HIS TRAVELS.
>> I'M FROM A GENERATION OF
RADIO FREE EUROPE AND WE ALL
REMEMBER HOW THE ENSLAVED
COUNTRY -- AND PROPER
INFORMATION LEGAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THE WORLD.
I CAN REMEMBER A TIME WHEN WE
USED TO LISTEN TO RADIO FREE
WORLD.
THE ONLY VOICE FROM THE FREE
WORLD FOR ENSLAVED PEOPLE IN
POLAND.
>> THOMAS KEPT IS THE FORMER
CEO
OF RADIO FOR EUROPE AND AN
EXPERT IN RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> DO YOU THINK SOME PEOPLE IN
RUSSIA WILL BE RECEPTIVE TO
THESE MESSAGES OR WILL THEY SAY
WHY IS THERE AN AMERICAN
SENDING
ME A TEXT MESSAGE?
>> WELL CERTAIN NUMBER OF
PEOPLE
WILL SAY ABSOLUTELY THIS IS
HOSTILE PROPAGANDA, THIS IS
SPAM, AN ATTEMPT, IT IS
PSYCHOLOGICAL WAR AGAINST US,
BUT MANY OTHERS WILL BE
GRATEFUL
FOR SOME INFORMATION THAT THEY
ARE HAVING TROUBLE TO GET AND
MAYBE AFFECTED BY THE FACT THAT
THERE IS SOMEONE OUT AT THE END
OF THE COMMUNICATION WHO REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM THEM.
>> OTHER TAKING A DIFFERENT
APPROACH ON THE TELEGRAM MAP,
THEY HAVE AMASKED 300,000
MEMBERS AND SENDS OUT LISTS OF
RUB SHEN WEBSITE TOSS ATTACK.
>> YOU'RE A CODE ER, NOT A
GUNNER.
>> THAT US TRUE.
>> WE
>> WE SPOKE TO HIM OVER THE
PHONE AND HE SAID HE IS IN
UKRAINE.
>> YOU TOOK DOWN FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICES FOR TAKE OUT IN
RUSSIA.
I THINK I SAW YOU GUYS TARGETED
SOME BANKING SERVICES IN
RUSSIA.
I MEAN, WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
TARGETING RUSSIAN CITIZENS,
PEOPLE IN RUSSIA.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS FAIR?
>> WELL, THAT IS EXACTLY THE
POINT THAT WE WANTED TO CONVEY.
WE
WANT THOSE PEOPLE TO FEEL THAT
THE WAR HAS STARTED.
MANY PEOPLE IN RUSSIA DON'T FEEL
THAT THE WAR IS FAIR, AND WE
WANT THEM TO FEEL THAT.
>> DONNY JOINS US NOW.
IS THAT KIND OF CYBER ATTACKS --
IS THAT LEGAL?
>> YEAH, ANDERSON, THIS IS A
DIFFICULT ONE IN THAT UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT IS PUSHING PEOPLE.
ITS MINISTERS ARE TWEEZING ABOUT
THE I.T. ARMY, WHICH IS TELLING
PEOPLE TO GO ATTACK THESE
RUSSIAN WEBSITES.
BUT CERTAINLY A LOT OF THIS
ACTIVITY IS ILLEGAL.
WE ASKED A U.S. STATES
DEPARTMENT SPOKESPERSON ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE SOME AMERICANS --
THERE ARE 300,000 MEMBERS OF
THIS SO-CALLED I.T. ARMY.
THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT
THREADED THAT NEEDLE CAREFULLY
SAYING UKRAINE